JASON SILVA: There's a great
line by the philosopher Alain
de Botton where
he says, we don't
cry because something is sad.
We cry because something
is more beautiful
than we expected it to be.
So essentially, we
are moved to tears
in order to address, to
correct an imbalance,
a cognitive dissonance
between what we expected
and what we actually
found, to realize
that what you found was
more conducive to your needs
than what you thought
you were looking for,
the sort of the
serendipity of melancholy,
of aesthetic experience,
when it feels like something
is unexpectedly so much
more moving than you thought
it would be.
This is such a mystery.
These moments in
which we are moved
to the point of
tears, that define
our lives, these moments
of aestheticized,
italicized experience,
these moments
pregnant with
significance, these moments
of revelatory ecstasy,
ecstatic signification.
It's such a cool idea.
I love it when music does it
to me, when theater does it
to me, when films
do it to me, when
staring into the iris of a
lover's eye does it to me.
You get the goosebumps.
You get the shivers
down your spine.
These moments.
Mmm.
You don't cry because
something is sad.
You cry because it
is more beautiful
than you expected it to be.